oh my christ what the hell that's good
oh it makes me feel like i've got a
hangover oh my god
it tastes like
um it does it it just tastes it tastes
like guts
so yeah we'd have this at you know any
sort of event i guess this is the drink
that's the best
petrol
[Music]
how are you good are you yeah good becky
yeah what's your name
zan are
like what is it i think it's like lamb
guts
got got yeah
but just think about it as a better
version of black people okay
i don't yeah i don't i don't eat black
honey so
it's delicious it usually comes with
neeps and taxis and we celebrate robert
burns and we like
get storage and toast the haggis and
usually we end up quite drunk
get a sword into the gut yeah you toast
a hagger
okay yeah that's scotland for you that's
us
but you just gotta go for it so let's do
this oh you ready smells like fall
embrace it worst things have happened
okay
um it does it does
it just tastes it tastes like guts it
tastes like that
told you that you can't think that that
is horrible
and what do we have here a cornish pasty
shall we crack in sure i may it may bang
or do we
like bite it or like
that's not good oh it's thick isn't it a
lot
hmm dry
well you warmed up the guts but you
didn't warm up the pastry i guess isn't
looking so bad now is it i'm just gonna
go back to my haircut
you're literally oh my god you're
snorting what the hell
i don't have any food today this is
gorgeous you're not even eating your own
food tell me more about this what's in
this
tell me tell me the origins give me the
history the cornish pasty
was brought about from where's cornland
cornwall
[Laughter]
i will declare the dry cornish pasty as
the winner
over the intestines of a god knows what
animal
i'm gonna stick by haggis but i would
say that you do need neeps and tattoos
to make it extra delicious
ah mac and cheese pie what are they
oh my gosh if you had a mac and cheese
pie no they
are i don't even know what this is is
this a scotch egg can i tell you more
about
the mac and cheese pie yeah what's going
on with all that good it's literally
like you have pie crust and then you
have
mac and cheese on the inside usually i
have it with ketchup and it's super
[ __ ] okay
slotted it's [ __ ] yeah that is glad
you love it
honestly you're in for such a treat okay
that isn't
as if you didn't have enough carbs
you've just wrapped it oh yes when
you're feeling [ __ ]
when you're feeling fluffy and you know
what i'm gonna have pie pastry i'm gonna
have carb i'm gonna have cheese i'm
going to be a [ __ ]
so this is a pork pie similar to the
porridge pasty
okay not made in cornwall where is it
made
that's manchester
that's what i thought all right let's
crack it open look at the size
comparison
i know how you guys doing with your bmi
oh wow you keep heating up scottish
foods and you're not heating up england
like that is
that is so cold oh wow okay this does
look really good
you need some ketchup yeah however
that is delicious mmm do you like it
slotty you know what that is so
good wow okay
shall i crack this open yep i'm a stone
cold pork pie
is it meant to be that hard right
i'll make you use my finger to this bad
boy okay
again quite dry it's not as bad as i
thought
no i think scotland win there that is
amazing
wow i could i'm just gonna go back to my
mac and cheese pie
yeah oh yeah just me alone
me and my bag having a good time
that is so good scotland
my gosh that's a lot of red that is a
lot of red and orange i like it
no well this is british so it's called
tyson the great
british pop never heard of it
oh i love that mmm needs some ice and
some alcohol
oh wow i like that a lot ties are for
the win
here we go have you heard of iron brew
um yes i don't live under a rock
this is key for when you're hungover oh
really yeah yeah yeah so the next day
you'll generally drink three or four of
these to try and make things better
again
okay a strong man's strength now you
have to wait you have to why isn't it
right until you open it listen to that
crack oh
okay oh my christ what the hell
that's good oh it makes me feel like
i've got a hangover oh my god
it tastes like pass wow that tastes like
actual piss
that is horrible you're going to have a
lot of scottish people after you that
doesn't go with anything
but i really feel like you can have this
when you need energy you can have it on
a hangover it's not reliant on alcohol
it's going to give you a good buzz it's
going to get your dentist happy
all right yeah christ okay fine should
we agree to this great
it's a draw it's a draw fine
what the hell hello old speckled pen
oh wow scottish famous whiskey english
pale ale
whiskey whiskey aged three years because
we've had a couple more years on top but
yeah nice
is whiskey scottish oh yeah this is kind
of stuffed in born drinks
old speckled hen tell me more about that
owes its name not to a bird but to a car
standard english trying to be quite posh
you just tell it how it is
okay should we crack it open should we
go with whiskey first
okay cheers so is this meant to be like
on ice
i guess it could be wow that is strong
oh that's spicy
so yeah we'd have this at you know any
sort of event i guess this is the drink
that's the best
petrol i think what the hell it tastes
like petrol
strong stuff wow do you like it no no
fair enough but i can appreciate that
it's
some sort of luxury
you can tell i'm not a bear oh spillage
is lickage
all right can you tell me anything about
old speckled hair i can't i'm afraid
sorry no
yum i feel like what i need for this is
to be in a beer garden with some sun
yes but i just feel it's like less
intense where it's like if i were to
drink that i'd be like having a one
woman party
you know what i mean i'd be ready on
your own yeah
yeah crying into some ben jerry's yeah
probably or some hagger
yes whiskey and haggis yeah that might
actually add to the flavor i think i
would
hence why people get so drunk when we
have robert burns parties
i actually really like this now
i actually vote scotland sorry i'm
actually gonna vote england
we can't do this we can't keep i think
we're swapping
no it's what usually um glaswegians and
i don't know about the eden burgers but
ouijas in the street of glasgow maybe
around 11 pm at night we'll drink this
and only this
tonic wine you know that they're
drinking it because your whole mouth
turns purple
and it's a really really classy classy
drink yes green it's classy doesn't it
so we're gonna have a really good time
after this okay on the other end of
sophistication we have the gin and tonic
this might
illustrate our differences in the best
way possible what's the um percentage in
this one
let's see
15 okay quite good yeah okay
oh it smells like rabina cheers cheers
oh wow and you like that i mean i
wouldn't say i love it but i'd say i
appreciate
that part of my culture it's very sugary
isn't it i'll always back people if they
want to drink this
you guys got a sugar problem up there we
don't have tea let's wash that one
just wash it down with a lovely gin and
tonic there we go okay
here we go
so good that's lovely i can smell the
freshly cut grass
i just want to be by a pool i can hear
the wimbledon tennis balls
yeah that's so good i actually have to
stop because i will download it
i think we both have to agree on this
one i think
we do yes i think ding ding ding come to
the dark
[Applause]
great britain together yeah united front
[Laughter]
sorry oh my god there's still some line
this is a it's a crumpet
[Music]